so now I need your help I need your help
I need you to make up some tables for me
I'll make up one but then I'm gonna need
you all to make up your own one okay
here's what I'm gonna try it out make a
little subheading which is times tables
now we're gonna do really small tribes
tables okay maybe the times tables that
you memorize good memorize the furthest
what was the first L but you got up to
your name
well yeah so you guys at 12 times 12
would be 1944 good okay
now two by 12 that's a B times day well
I believe you're studying one that's two
by two okay now if you're multiplying
two sets of numbers you actually end up
having a three by three square coz watch
you've got your multiplication that's
what you're doing okay now here's where
I need your help I need you to make up
some numbers here okay so what examples
are three - two - okay now these numbers
actually you know that's right the
numbers don't have to be in order but
the important thing I need you to get is
that I want these two numbers here first
two in the row and the column I'd like
them to be positive okay so you got
positive 3 and positive 4 and over the
last two you on the outside see I'll let
them both to be negative you can come
with any numbers you like in fact I'd
like you to come up with different
numbers that person next to you and the
people around you okay then I'd like you
to write down one of these things called
remember we just gave them a name we
just call them something these are the
products right you should have four
products so for my example I'm going to
have 4 times 3 which is 12 4 times
negative 6 which is
I think that's minus 20 negative 24
sorry negative 2 times 3 what's that
gonna be negative 6 and this last one
this will just be 12
what ok now this way example right I
want you to draw your own one in fact
all right you guys are pretty quick to
Eric and you can all draw two each but
the numbers have to be different
different to mine do to the person next
to you and different tables the to the D
drop okay so I'll give you a few minutes
for them up nice and even with a walk
they will come together with share our
findings the first thing I wanna point
out is one of them namely this one this
one doesn't exactly follow the pattern
that we've got for the rest of them it's
not wrong so let me double check it it's
not wrong all the numbers are right but
it is arranged a little differently
because you can see they're negative up
here is at the top where is the one I
set up and most of them the neck is down
the bottom the numbers are all still
fine but that's why I'm not going to
look at that one this one here is also a
little almost with the left-hand side
the board it must have some issues with
this one here also has a question mark
over but I'll leave that for a minute
okay let's have a look at all of these
ones on the right by the way lesson for
young beginners on people up the back
how you doing reading these can you make
them out so it's not they don't give you
cold um just a tricky thing you know
when you're writing you're like I'm
writing this on my page for me so that I
can see it from the distance that I am
from the page but I'm gonna be asking
you all to join me on the front of the
room eight times not just that and when
you're doing it you know I don't just
write things huge because I have bad
eyesight even though I do have bad
eyesight
I draw those huge so that everyone can
see so let's have a look at this one
first shall we um six by two six times
to 12
yes no yes
ok 6 times minus 5 negative 5 is
negative 30 yes
if we did something very similar to that
just now did we negative 2 times 2 the
gives us negative 4 at home and that 10
looks good as well okay
now this one is the same I think that's
all fine already what's that one this
one this one's fine
this one I need a calculator another
chance okay I'm gonna give it the step
okay this one is in the same boat as
this one over here now what I want you
to do is have a look at the four that
I've gone five four ticks on okay
there's something in common between them
all mathematics is all about patterns I
in fact it would be called patterns if
someone has made up all that working out
what trim did you see that that binds us
all together what's theme is in covers
with all of them okay now I wonder if
anyone can see what's going on all the
numbers are different but what we have
the same is where the negatives come on
does anyone want to have a stabbing what
relationship they can see between all
the ones that you think
okay so that's that's their the negative
60 and negative 3 over here that's what
I'm putting a question mark on question
mark and question mark okay now the
reason we didn't question mark there is
because what's going on what's going on
now I'm actually pretty hands there for
a second because I'm suspecting so if
you are I then you see it but others are
you doing I don't aspire for them I want
to try and get bits again up all right
now you remember yesterday when we were
looking at subtraction
okay we said that minus a negative of
every single ever no different you
remember that what was the difference
between them we used two different kinds
of words to describe them yep exactly
right - is a verb something's happening
negative is an adjective it describes a
number okay that's how they different
but they are very the same because we
have this something there about okay
when we looked at the -2 negative and
they came together the - of a negative
become just like how plus sign don't
they supposed to be it's kind of like I
think you know who uses it's like
turning around and then turning around
again okay so you end up in the same
direction you started okay which is fine
now it's the same with multiplication
okay so I'm gonna try and tease this
apart for you right and we're gonna talk
about this in a minute okay so which is
why I mentioned it right let's pick out
let's go with let's go with this number
because it's a bit smaller so we're
trying to work out -1 sorry negative 1
times negative 3
now help us out here I'm going to break
this apart into pieces
okay so negative 1 I can write it in
terms of multiplication I can call it
negative 1 times 1 you're like that's no
big deal what's the point I just added a
1 ok what I'm going to use the same kind
of pattern yeah
negative 3 right I can rewrite that in
terms of notice 1 inch of Japan is 2 I
can write it as negative 1 times 3 said
okay so far
and by the way you're like man that's a
lot of brackets why is show me breakfast
well I suppose okay
the reason why I show your record so you
can see what's negative that's nice now
remember we just said multiplication is
commutator I can change the order of
these numbers however I like and the
answer will still be the same
Thanks so I'm gonna put this name is one
of this thing you want together okay so
I've rearranged it can you see are we
happy with that look alright so far but
hold on a minute we talked about how a
negative and a minus ready they come
together the negative the - come
together they become for us the same
thing is going to happen here okay that
negative one and the other negative one
they were going to cancel each other out
the two negatives will become positive
which is what most of you have noticed
here and and over here as well two
negatives become a positive they're just
going to be
as you know we want supply something by
one doesn't change okay and that's why
the final answer is just great
so therefore we'll be getting ok-hee are
this actually should be positive 60
because you see how the two negatives
are going to cancel each other out and
over here this should be sorry
let's try to generalize what does
generalize mean I don't know what that
word means
hands up who's heard the word before
turn it doesn't know what it means but
you've heard okay most of you hear the
word what kinds of places do you
actually hear it say like in a sentence
yeah yeah well done okay as you know I
had to work for this lesson generalize
generalize means you take something
specific a whole bunch of examples these
are all specific examples with specific
numbers and can you think about what
happens generally what happens all the
time
okay I want you to drive me one last
time stable but it's a bit weird because
it's not going to have any numbers in
okay same size as before multiplication
sign in the top left indicate that's
what I'm doing it but this time I'm
going to pretend no numbers I'm just
going to have types of numbers a
positive and a positive a negative
now everyone has seen so far that when
you multiply two positive numbers
together always without exception you're
always going to get another positive
number when you do a negative times a
positive and everyone without exception
has noticed that you'll get a negative
number
now I said negative times positive this
square here is positive times negative
does it matter which ones first
it doesn't why not that's right so you
can see why we're talking about this one
all right last one we were just dwelling
on this may be your times negative is
okay so let's take this table and
translate it into work so I'm going to
write like it's positive that's actually
equal to just put the same conclusion in
two words right positive times negative
like we said it's gonna be leave
I think we can finish us off can we wash
I made mine extra what do we do
yep well I'm gonna come to that I lost
the one that I did thought it was here
wasn't it which was negative times
positive so the order was different but
as we've noticed with multiplication the
order is unimportant
so it's still going to be negative and
then our last one was negative
okay now one more thing that you can put
onto there again if you have a different
color do you see here positive times
positive positive or negative we call
out the sign of the number that's where
we talked about that sign direction of
the number the sign of these two is the
same and you end up with a positive the
sign of these two numbers the factors if
you like are different so you get a
negative the signs of these are differ
as well and the last one went in the
same again we were talking about the
negatives cancelling each other out so
one more way that you might put it all
in your textbook might say is that when
the signs match you'll get a positive
and when the sides don't match you get a
negative hey well done you've done a
great job concentrating so far I'm gonna
ask you to write down one more sentence
in a second but I want you to get up and
stretch them around
stretch move ready get someone by
accident okay
thanks I rise you can take a seat now in
the exercise I'm about to show you but
you actually win every much time to do
so
very luckily for you you're actually
gonna get a home with free day today um
you get these kinds of questions so you
will look at these later on right yeah
something like this the numbers like
this how would I read that just I just
put it down at the door
how do you read that yes five now five
sometimes right that's what it's it
actually has a special name we would
call that that's of an S five squared
right or squaring a number okay now the
important thing I'm introducing this to
you because you'll see it in your
exercise right this is this not mcneir
the - it's called an index for power
okay now powers just like multiplication
right how is our an abbreviation is
Lawson how is an abbreviation just like
multiplication was an abbreviation
what are powers an abbreviation Oh what
are they in short form all what do I
have them here on the right hand side I
have multiplication don't I so a power
is a short form of wait writing
multiplication